for several years now we've been engaged
in a national debate about sexual
assault on campus no question it's
crucial that young people understand the
ground rules for consent but that's
where the conversation about sex is
ending and in that vacuum of information
the media and the internet that new
digital street corner are educating our
kids for us if we truly want young
people to engage safely ethically and
give enjoyably it's time to have open
honest discussion about what happens
after yes and that includes breaking the
biggest taboo of all and talking to
young people about women's capacity for
and entitlement to sexual pleasure yeah
come on ladies it's just awesome I spent
three years talking to girls ages 15 to
20 about their attitudes and experience
of sex and what I found was that while
young women may feel entitled to engage
in sexual behavior they don't
necessarily feel entitled to enjoy it
takes a sophomore at the Ivy League
college who told me I come from a long
line of smart strong women my
grandmother was a firecracker my mom is
a professional my sister and I are loud
and that's our form of feminine power
she then proceeded to describe her sex
life to me a series of one-off hookups
starting when she was 13 that were not
especially responsible not especially
reciprocal and not especially enjoyable
she shrugged I guess we girls are just
socialized to be these docile creatures
who don't express our wants or needs
wait a minute I replied didn't you just
tell me what a smart strong woman you
are
she Hamden HOD I guess she finally said
no one told me that
art strong image applies to sex I should
probably say right up top that despite
the hype teenagers are not engaging in
intercourse more often or at a younger
age than they were 25 years ago they are
however engaging in other behavior and
when we ignore that when we label that
as not sex that opens the door to risky
behavior and disrespect that's
particularly true of oral sex which
teenagers consider to be less intimate
than intercourse growth would tell me
it's no big deal
like they'd all read the same
instruction manual at least if boys were
on the receiving end young women had
lots of reasons for participating it
made them feel desired it was a way to
boost social status sometimes it was a
way to get out of an uncomfortable
situation as a freshman at West Coast
College said to me a girl will give a
guy a [ __ ] at the end of the night
because she doesn't want to have sex
with him and he expects to be satisfied
so if I want him to leave and I don't
want anything to happen I heard so many
stories of girls performing one-sided
oral sex that I started asking what if
every time you were along with a guy he
told you to get him a glass of water
from the kitchen and he never got you a
glass of water or if he did it was like
you want me to a you know totally
begrudging you wouldn't stand for it but
it wasn't always that boys didn't want
him it was that girls didn't want them
to girls expressed a sense of shame
around the genitals a sense that they
were simultaneously icky and sacred
woman's feelings about their genitals
has been directly linked to their
enjoyment of sex yet Debbie Rebennack a
researcher at Indiana University
believes that girl's genitals self-image
is under siege with more pressure than
ever to see them as unacceptable in
their natural state according to
research about three-quarters of college
women we
lose their pubic hair all of it at least
on occasion and more than half do so
regularly girls would tell me that hair
removal made them feel cleaner that it
was a personal choice so kind of
wondered if left alone on a desert
island if this was how they would choose
to spend their time and when I pushed
further a darker motivation emerged
avoiding humiliation guys act like they
would be disgusted by it one young woman
told me no one wants to be talked about
like that
the rise in pubic hair removal reminded
me of the 1920s when women first started
regularly shaving their armpits and
their legs that's when the flapper
dresses came into style and women's
limbs were suddenly visible open to
public scrutiny there's a way that I
think that this too is a sign that a
girl's most intimate part is open to
public scrutiny open to critique to
becoming more about how it looks to
someone else than how it feels to her
the shaving trend has sparked another
rise in labiaplasty labiaplasty which is
the trimming of the inner and outer
labia is the fastest growing cosmetic
surgery among teenage girls
it rose 80 percent between 2014 and 2015
and whereas girls under 18 comprise two
percent of all cosmetic surgeries they
are five percent of labiaplasty the most
sought after look incidentally in which
the outer labia appears fused like a
clamshell is called wait for it the
Barbie
I trust I don't have to tell you that
Barbie is a made of plastic and B has no
genitalia
the lady a plastic tread has become so
worrisome that the American College of
Obstetricians and Gynaecologists has
issued a statement on the procedure
which is rarely medically indicated has
not been proven safe and whose side
effects include scarring numbness pain
and diminished sexual sensation now
admittedly and blessedly the number of
girls involved is still quite small but
you could see them as Canaries in a coal
mine telling us something important
about the way girls see their bodies
Sarah McLellan a psychologist at the
University of Michigan coined what is my
favorite phrase ever in talking about
all of this intimate justice that's the
idea that sex has political as well as
personal implications just like who does
the dishes in your house or who vacuums
the rug and it raises similar issues
about inequality about economic
disparity violence physical and mental
health intimate justice asks us to
consider who is entitled to engage in an
experience who is entitled to enjoy it
who is the primary beneficiary and how
does each partner define good enough
honestly I think those questions are
tricky and sometimes traumatic for adult
women to confront but when we're talking
about girls I just kept coming back to
the idea that their early sexual
experience shouldn't have to be
something that they get over in her work
McClellan found that young women were
more likely than young men to use their
partners pleasure as a measure of their
satisfaction so they'd say things like
if he's sexually satisfied then I'm
sexually satisfied young men were more
likely to measure their satisfaction
by their own orgasm young women also
defined bad sex differently in the
largest-ever survey ever conducted on
American sexual behavior they reported
pain in their sexual encounters 30
percent of the time they also use words
like depressing humiliating degrading
the young men never used that language
so when young women report sexual
satisfaction levels that are equal to or
greater than young man's and they do in
research that can be deceptive if a girl
goes into an encounter hoping that it
won't hurt wanting to feel close to her
partner and expecting him to have an
orgasm
she'll be satisfied if those criteria
are met and there's nothing wrong with
wanting to feel close to your partner or
wanting him to be happy and orgasm isn't
the only measure of an experience but
absence of pain that's a very low bar
for your own sexual fulfillment
listening to all of this from thinking
about it I began to realize that we
performed a kind of psychological
clitoridectomy on American girls
starting an infancy parents of baby boys
are more likely to name all their body
parts but we still say here's your
peepee parents of baby girls go right
from navel to knees and they leave this
whole situation in here unnamed there's
no better way to make something
unspeakable than not to name it then
kids go into their puberty education
classes and they learn that boys have
erections and ejaculations and girls
have periods and unwanted pregnancy and
they see that internal diagram of a
woman's reproductive system you know the
one that looks kind of like a steer head
and it always Gray's out between the
legs so we never say vulva we certainly
never say clitoris no surprise fewer
than half of teenage girls aged 14 to 17
have ever masturbated and then they go
into their partnered experience and we
expect that somehow they'll think sex is
about them that they'll be able to
articulate their needs their desires
their limits
it's unrealistic here's something zone
growth investment in their partners
pleasure remains regardless of the
gender of the partner so in same sex
encounters the orgasm gap disappears and
young women climax at the same rate as
men lesbian and bisexual girls would
tell me that they felt liberated to get
off the script free to create an
encounter that worked for them gay girls
also challenged the idea of first
intercourse as the definition of
virginity
not because intercourse isn't a big deal
but it's worth questioning why we
consider this one act which most girls
associate with discomfort or pain to be
the line in the sand of sexual adulthood
so much more meaningful so much more
transformative than anything else and
it's worth considering how this is
serving girls whether it's keeping them
safer from disease coercion betrayal
assault whether it's encouraging
mutuality and caring what it means about
the way they see other sex acts whether
it's giving them more control over and
joy in their experience and what it
means about gay teens who can have
multiple sex partners without
heterosexual intercourse so I asked the
gay girl that I met how'd you know you
weren't a virgin anymore she said she
had to google it
and Google wasn't sure she finally
decided that she wasn't a virgin anymore
after she'd had her first orgasm with a
partner and I thought whoa what if just
for a second we imagined that was the
definition again now because intercourse
isn't a big deal of course it is but it
isn't the only big deal and rather than
thinking about sex is a race to a goal
this helps us Rican sexualize it as a
pool of experiences that include warmth
affection arousal desire touch intimacy
and it's worth asking young people who's
really the more sexually experienced
person the one who makes out with a
partner for three hours and experiments
with sensual tension and communication
or the one who gets wasted at a party
and hooks up with a random in order to
dump their virginity before they get to
college the only way that shifts in
thinking can happen though is if we talk
to young people more about sex if we
normalize those discussions integrating
them into everyday life talking about
those intimate acts in a different way
the way we mostly have changed in the
way that we talk about women in the
public realm consider a survey of 300
randomly chosen girls from a Dutch and
an American University two similar
universities talking about their early
experience of sex the Dutch girls
embodied everything we say we want from
our girls they had fewer negative
consequences like disease pregnancy
regret more positive outcomes like being
able to communicate with their partner
who they said they knew very well
preparing for the experience responsibly
enjoying themselves what was their
secret the Dutch girl said that their
doctors teachers and parents talk to
them candidly from an early age
about sex pleasure and the importance of
mutual trust what's more while American
parents weren't necessarily less
comfortable talking about sex we tend to
frame those conversations entirely in
terms of risk and danger
whereas Dutch parents talk about
balancing responsibility and joy I have
to tell you as a parent myself that hit
me hard because I know
had I not delved into that research I
would have talked to my own child about
contraception about disease protection
about consent because I'm a modern
parent and I would have thought
job well done now I know that's not
enough I also know what I hope for for
our girls I want them to see sexuality
as a source of self-knowledge creativity
and communication
despite its potential risks I want them
to be able to revel in their body's
sensuality without being reduced to it I
want them to be able to ask for what
they want in bed and to get it I want
them to be safe from unwanted pregnancy
disease cruelty dehumanization violence
if they are assaulted I want them to
have recourse from their schools their
employers the courts it's a lot to ask
but it's not too much as parents
teachers advocates and activists we have
raised a generation of girls to have a
voice to expect egalitarian treatment in
the home in the classroom in the
workplace now it's time to demand that
intimate justice in their personal lives
as well thank you
you
[Music]